наш
брифінг лідер Партії європейська
Солідарність п'ятий президент України
Петро Порошенко спів голова фракції
європейської солідарності Ірина ращенко
і голова комітету євроінтеграції Івана
линша Я дуже дякую перш за все за те що
ви
відгукнулися на запрошення на бріфінг ці
дні зараз 10 днів які залишилися до
визначної для України події в брюселі до
засі саміту Європейської ради де буде
прийматися доленосне рішення
про відкриття процесу переговорів до
вступ щодо України і Молдови і на
сьогоднішній день Я вважаю що кожен
українець кожен державник має зробити
максимум від нього що залежить для того
щоб забезпечити позитивне рішення 1415
Брюсселі 10 років минуло з часів
революції гідності
коли вступ забезпечував ні президент
Прем'єр спікер чи Голова парламенту а
вступи забезпечив український народ і
саме
прагнення забезпечити членство в
Європейському Союзі і на сьогоднішній
день має бути разом з перемогою у війні
нашим головним мотивуючим фактором На
жаль останніми діями останніми днями
своїми незаконними діями українська
влада
зірвала поїздки народних депутатів від
опозиції для зустрічі з ключовими
лідерами від яких залежить вступ в
Євросоюз Та надання нам фінансової та
збройної допомоги і ми точно наголошуємо
що це поведінка української влади
категорично несумісна з європейською
політичною культурою та вкрай
недоречнона напередодні засідання
Європейської ради відверто кажучи грає
на руку нашим ворогам грає на руку
скептикам в Європейському Союзі додає їм
додаткову аргументацію і це не може нас
залишати остронь лишати
бездіяльними
на рішенням нашої фракції було
прийнято позиція щодо підготовки
спеціально окремої постанови постанови
Верховної Ради яку ми вимагаємо прийняти
негайно завтра скликати позачергове
засідання Верховної Ради
України зараз проект цієї постанови нами
розроблений зареєстрований за номером 14
937 і він спрямований на звернення до
країн членів Європейського Союзу до
голів держав та урядів що
вся українська громада весь український
народ весь політиком і Влада і опозиція
незважаючи на
будь-які питання які виникають в
середині країни звертаються з проханням
забезпечити позитивне голосування по
відкриттю переговорів доступ для України
14-15го числа тут докладно викладені всі
наші аргументи тут докладно є заклик до
єдності єдності наших партнерів єдності
всередині країни і єдності навколо
збройних сил Ми хочемо скористатися цією
можливістю і закликати всіх народних
депутатів е-е підписатися і стати
співавторами цієї постанови парламенту і
підтримати необхідність проведення
якнайскорше голосування позачергового і
прийняття цього звернення це
ее розіб'є будь-які спроби атаки щодо
нібито якоїсь дестабілізації яка
перешкоджає прийняття рішень на
підтримку України Звичайно що єдність -
це дії
і ми для забезпечення цієї єдності маємо
діяти додатково до цього ми вважаємо за
необхідне щоби і керівництво держави
включно з президентом підготували візит
до брюсселя перед 14-м числом мали б
можливість зустрітися з усіма без
виключення лідерами Європейського Союзу
і зробити все від них залежне для того
щоби забезпечити позитивне голосування
Ми хочемо наголосити що вимагання
скликання засідання парламенту потребує
не лише прийняття зазначеної постанови а
і прийняття низки законів які Україна
зобов'язалася прийняти перед проведенням
саміту цей закон про чисельність
національного антикорупційного агентства
це є закон про
незалежність сапу і Набу цей закон про
національні меншини і Хочу наголосити що
європейська Солідарність бере дуже
активну участь в остаточному узгодженні
тексту законопроекту в тому числі і
сьогодні ранком ми задоволені що вже
після реєстрації зазначеного урядового
законопроекту низка уже більше половини
наших зауважень в робочій групі вра і
законопроект Про національні меншини
буде перевнесено при цьому Ми хочемо
наголосити що всі пропозиції
європейської солідарності повністю
відповідають висновку веніціанської
комісії І лише забезпечить
подальши збалансований підхід в тому
числі і до розвитку української мови і
захисту інтересів національних меншин
інші законопроекти які також Україна
взяла на себе зобов'язання ще там два
Мені здається я думаю що більш докладно
на цьому зупиниться Іванка
клімпушценсадз як голова комітету
європейської інтеграції також буде
зроблено в той же час ми категорично
просто обурені бездумною і незаконною
заявою СБУ з публічною критикою на
адресу європейської солідарності з
публічною критикою на адресу е
країн-членів ЄС країн-членів НАТО е ми
вважаємо що офісу президента дуже добре
відомо яка посадова особа дала службі
вказівку випускати цю шкідливу заяву і
де-факто три рази змінювати е редакцію
цієї заяви перетворюючи Службу безпеки
України де-факто в telegram-канал офісу
президента Я вважаю що та людина яка від
дала цю незаконну вказівку службі і її
слід відрядити до Будапешту з чіткою
директивою переконати угорське
керівництво підтримати переговори ЄС з
Україною Ви якщо не можете це зробити
самі то не заважайте іншим в той же час
я хотів би принципово ще раз наголосити
що відрядження моє яке було скасо вано
стосувалася виключно поїздки до Польщі
де були передбачені зустрічі із
керівництвом сейму з керівництвом
комітетів бо для нас зараз порядок
денний для Польщі дуже важливий це є
питання перевезників і питання
традиційної ролі адвокатав в
Європейському Союзі Польщі особливо це
пов'язано в зв'язку з зміною
е уряду польського за підсумками виборів
і в цій ситуації для нас є абсолютно
принциповим щоби ми ні в якому разі не
упустили ці можливості і уже одразу вже
після переговорів в Польщу у нас ми
передамо і квітки і резервацію готелів
була передбачена поїздка до Сполучених
Штатів Америки де планувалися зустрічі з
другого по сьме 7ьмого числа ми мали по
вернутися в Варшаву всю ніч їхати в
Україну для того щоби 8мого числа
Приступити до роботи в Верховній Раді
тому
абсолютно безпідставна я би так сказав
політична позиція коли Служба безпеки
України намагалися і намагаються
втягнути в атаку на єдність ми вважаємо
дуже обурливою тенденцію Бо коли у нас
спідслу служби як в Росії ФСБ будуть
проводити замість дипломатів зовнішню
політику це гарантовано призведе до
краху бо некомпетентність
ділітантство завжди несуть за собою дуже
небезпечні тенденції Крім того ми хотіли
би звернутися до уряду з вимогою негайно
розглянути і ухвалити адаптовану річну
національну програму українанато яка
була щойно прийнята на засідання Ради
українинато і її
успішно виконання має бути додатковою
підставою для прийняття рішення
вашингтонським самітом НАТО 24го року по
запрошенню України до членства і також
розпочатку процедури для нас цей має
доленосне рішення в тому числі і для
забезпечення наших
е безпекових питань Я хочу ще раз і ще
раз навести приклад Ізраїлю
Бо коли для Ізраїля стоїть питання
єдності то в перший день прем'єр-міністр
нетаньяху зустрівся з лідером опозиції і
вони прийняли рішення сформувати уряд
національної єдності ще раз наголошую
уряд національної єдності - Це не про
посади уряд національної єдності - це
про в
відповідальність і зараз популярні
рішення для України
закінчилися і зараз треба приймати
непопулярні рішення які забезпечать
безпеку і забезпечать вступ країни в ЄС
та НАТО і для того щоби розподілити
відповідальність для того щоби
продемонструвати єдність не на словах А
на ділі єдність в розумінні
Європейському а не в розумінні
telegramканалів президента і атаки на
опозицію з боку правоохоронних органів
спецслужб і єдиного марафона нам
безумовно треба це зробити Також ми
наголошуємо що парламент має врешті-решт
вийти з
підпілля парламент врешті-решт має
перейти до відкритої роботи Тим більше
що ціла низка народних депутатів
забезпечують і так пряму
трансляцію і це означає просто що
керівництво парламенту і парламент
ховається від
виборців ховається навіть не від
виборців від українського народу і треба
врешті-решт перестати думати про
рейтинги Про вибори про проведення тих
чи інших кроків які на це впливають
атакуючи опозицію і перейти до позиції
національної єдності і роботи на захист
України всі підстави для цього є
безумовно що що ми не можемо залишити
без реакції і незаконні дії керівництва
прикордонників незаконні дії керівництва
парламенту незаконні дії СБУ на яких їх
штовхає окремі особи в офісі президента
хочу вам наголосити що я дав доручення
своїм адвокатам І сьогодні і завтра
будуть подані низка юридичних документів
перше це є заява про злочин про
порушення кримінальної справи проти
керівництва парламенту яке прийняло
незаконне рішення воно не відповідає
закону Про статус народного депутата і
закону про
регламент і конституції і іншим законам
України і безумовно що це питання має
бути розслідуване вивчені всі обставини
і про це має бути проінформовано
суспільство також прийня
рішення про
оскарження постанови незаконної
постанови уряду яким всупереч
законодавства України всупереч
Конституції нормативними актами Кабінету
Міністрів обмежується діяльність
народних
депутатів якщо у представників владної
команди є проблеми коли під час
широкомасштабної агресії Вони відвідують
там тайланди омани барс ни і інше Це
внутрішня політична ситуація слуг народу
та інших політичних сил розбирайтеся з
цим саме але
перешкоджати депутатам в тому числі від
опозиції в тому числі від європейської
солідарності проведення зустрічі
двосторонній спікером конгресу
Сполучених Штатів Америки від яких
залежить виділення постановки на
голосування і прийняття рішення про
виділення 61 млрда доларів прийняття
рішення про перешкоджання зустрічм з
керівником комітетів конгресу в тому
числі комітету по
розвідці і від республіканської партії і
інших комітетів від демократичної партії
для того щоб забезпечити ефективне
голосування хтось за це точно має
понести відповідальність перешкоджання
нашої зустрічі в державному департаменті
з керівництвом держдепу з пентагоном з
керівництвом пентагону Це точно має бути
покарано і тому будуть подані відповідні
позиції і в адміністративні суди щодо
скасування відповідних актів Кабінету
Міністрів і в верховний суд щодо
скасування відповідних актів Верховної
Ради і указу президента і ми просимо
вашої уваги і щодо юридично Звертаю
увагу щодо нашого юридичного
обґрунтування і щодо позицій по захисту
демократії свободи слова верховенства
права тому що коли ми говоримо про
перспективи членства про вступ то першим
питанням є копенгагенські критерії і ці
копенгагенські критерії так і записано
права людини демократія Свобода слова
верховянство права і ми не маємо на
сьогоднішній день давати жодних
аргументів тим хто хоче зупинити цей наш
рух і ее в даному випадку європейська
Солідарність ще раз повертає увагу будь
ласка Зверніть увагу на постанови які ми
Закликаємо і щоб не дати можливість
використати абсолютно безглузду помилку
влади яка лише створює нам проблеми Я
запрошую до слова
Іван Дякую Шановні колеги Дякую за те що
ви тут із нами продовжуючи те що
сьогодні ініціює європейська Солідар я
би наголосила на наступному ми маємо на
жаль дуже жорстокою ціною здобуте вікно
можливостей для України сьогодні і ми
звичайно як беручи участь у цьому
євроінтеграційному і євроатлантичному
Марафоні вже протягом останніх років
точно 10 років точно з Революції
гідності ми максимально докладаємо зараз
зусиль до того щоби всі країни члени
Європейського Союзу почули голос
спільний голос українців щодо того
наскільки критично важливо нам бачити це
світло в кінці тунелю Я дуже розраховую
на те що депутати інших фракцій дійсно
приєднаються до співавторства цієї
постанови і ми зможемо її якомога швидше
прийняти та її не треба приймати 19-го
чи там Вибачте чи 13-го числа прямо
безпосередньо перед засіданням
Європейської ради
її треба ухвалити завтра
зібравшись нагально для того щоби можна
було опрацювати всім країнам-членам ті
аргументи які ми пропонуємо зараз на на
цьому останньому етапі і так для нас
критично важливо щоби ті законопроекти
які вже були проголосовані в першому
читанні були винесені і доопрацьовані
Верховною Раду дою до другого читання
яке стосується дійсно і збільшення
кількості працівників на набу і
збільшення Незалежності спеціалізованої
антикорупційної прокуратури і уточнення
повноважень національного агентства з
запобігання корупції і
також зміни до закону про національні
спільноти І меншини у відповідності до
пропозиції венеційської комісії Я думаю
що тут дуже важливо що європейська
Солідарність як виступаючи з
державницьких позицій точно намагається
за пропонувати ті ті речі як правильно
сформулювати норми цього закону для того
щоб вони відповідали і рекомендаціям і
національним інтересам України є ще один
закон законопроєкт Який передбачений
тими додатковими завданнями Це закон Про
лобіювання який Верховна Рада України
має час над яким попрацювати приблизно
до березня місяця тому ми розраховуємо
на те що зараз зробивши додаткову роботу
і що колеги теж до неї долучаться Ми
все-таки знімемо максимальну кількість
застережень від тих скептиків які
користуються приводами для того щоби
щоби не ну не отримати єдності у рішенні
Європейської ради І ми переконані що
тільки спільнодія а саме дія вона дасть
відповіді на ці питання і тоді ми
розуміємо що буде рішення про Якщо нам
все вдасться буде рішення про відкриття
перемовин про членство про ее вступ
України до Європейського союзу а вже в
середині грудня І після того
продовжиться робота над додатковими
рекомендаціями так От я хотіла би
наголосити всі зосереджується на тому що
є ось ці кілька законопроектів і зараз
Верховна Рада вчергове Я наголошую
вчергове чомусь в останній момент
рухається по їхньому виконанню так як це
було перед тим як ми отримали
кандидатський статус в останні дні
Верховна Рада збиралася знову ж таки
перед тим як ми отримали проміжну оцінку
Європейської комісії Верховна Рада за
два дні до того збиралася і щось там
ухвалювала знову ж таки перед засіданням
і остаточною оцінкою Європейської
комісії в жовтні теж Верховна Рада
робила як студент в останній момент ми
не можемо зрозуміти чому немає системно
налагодженої роботи Верховної Ради
України по пріоритизації
євроінтеграційних законів саме до цього
ми заклика керівництво Верховної Ради
щоб вони зосередилися на своїх прямих
відповідальностях і обов'язках і два
слова щодо річної національної програми
про яку вже згадав Петро
Олексійович Ми раді чути про те що уряд
представив нашим партнерам на засіданні
Ради України
НАТО представив оновлену компактну
пріоритизовану річну національну
програму ми вимагаємо того щоби уряд
оприлюд в цей документ щоби уряд якомога
швидше його схвалив на своєму засіданні
для того щоб Верховна Рада України могла
включитися в виконання пріоритетних
завдань для того щоби ми не згаяли час
[музика]
перед самітом НАТО у літку цього року
через те що ми не хочемо опинитися в
ситуації коли ми перед самітом НАТО
знову там за місяць чи за півтора
почнемо в авральному режимі
реалізовувати ті завдання які необхідні
для того щоби ми
відповідали вимогам про членство в
північно-атлантичному альянсі і для того
щоб знову ж таки позбавити будь-яких
скептиків тих аргументів які можуть
використовуватися проти України Ну і
звичайно треба читати завжди між рядками
звіт Європейської комісії він стосовно
України це 150 сторінок зауважень і
рекомендацій так от мені би хотілося щоб
ми повернулися до того щоби насамперед
звернули увагу на те що парламент
зобов'язаний відновити свій контроль в
парламентсько-президентській Республіці
над виконавчими органами влади парламент
повернув свою суб'єктність що написано
чорним по- білому зокрема в цих
рекомендаціях Європейської комісії далі
дипломатичних формулювань стосовно
України На жаль буде менше Тому ми маємо
зосередитися на тому щоби до нас
претензій не було Це залежить від дій і
насамперед від дій влади дякую дякую е
колеги ми дуже раді вас бачити в офісі
європейської солідарності але переконані
що такі брифінги вже давно мають бути в
стінах Верховної Ради тому що зараз ми
говоримо про надзвичайно важливі речі
збереження державності збереження
демократії і врешті-решт сильну і
незалежну роботу інституцій Отже новина
перша сьогодні буде
перереєстрована законопроект про зміни
до Законів про національні меншини про
освіту про медіа які будуть виконувати
рекомендації венеційської комісії але в
той же час захистять українську мову від
спроби русифікації і зновутаки оцих от
нав'язувань русифікації можливих в
освіті а в медіа таке інше і ціі загрози
які мовні активісти які члени
європейської солідарності відразу
побачили в урядовому законопроекті про
що ми і сказали дійсно була дуже
історична реакція голови Верховної ради
на наше зауваження і представників уряду
але я зазначую що перед внесенням таких
важливих законопроектів порядок денний
треба все-таки консультуватися знаходити
консенсус із депутатами парламенту і з
активістами з громадськими організаціями
як це ми завжди робили 10 років поспіль
працюючи над законами щодо європейської
інтеграції Я дуже рада що всі поправки
нашої команди там нарешті враховані Отже
виходить ми були праві абсолютно і зараз
цей законопроект буде зареєстровано вже
від депутатів враховуючи наші пропозиція
Саме так ми вважаємо і потрібно
працювати над євроатлантичною
інтеграцією Наша команда яка має
відповідний досвід намагається донести
наступне всередині країни Ми маємо бути
професійними відповідальними і єди і
назовні точно так же от ви знаєте дійсно
сьогодні в ці дні дуже серйозні паралелі
є з 2013 роком коли дехто говорив що
тільки чотири людини в країні це кажара
всі пам'ятають Хто це це Азіров всі
пам'ятають Хто це це Рибак всі
пам'ятають Хто це І це Клюєв всі
пам'ятають Хто це і де вони зараз
начебто а і Янукович Да і Янукович мають
право вести від Країни тільки зовнішню
політику а зясу валося що Майдан і люди
український народ вів тоді цю насправді
дуже важливу асоціацію і я нагадаю що
тодішня опозиція зробила все для того
щоб угода була підписана лідер опозиції
Порошенко Кличко Яценюк тягнебок тоді
поїхали і Вільнюс і переконували наших
партнерів що ми маємо підписати угоду
про асоціацію маємо це зробити тому що
український народ це заслужив от саме
зараз наша команда про що Говорить
Україна за служила стати членом ЄС і
НАТО український народ своєю жартовністю
Українські збройні сили своєю
жартовністю і мужністю це повністю
заслужили Головна наша задача як
політиків не зробити помилок в ці 10
історичних днів і потім і далі і разом
працювати над адаптацією законодавства
разом переконувати не тільки дати
позитивний сигнал щодо членства України
в ЄС а і на саміті НАТО і тому ще раз
наголошуємо що ми вважаємо що для цього
ми маємо не тільки чотири там закони
виконати да і закон мовний а й
відповідати копенгагенським критеріям А
це свобода слова це демократія це
незалежний парламент це сильній
інституції друзі Київрада вже працює в
прямому ефірі іде трансляція звідти і
все добре От Наша команда давно вимагає
що журналісти мають повернутися в
Верховну Раду України ви би зараз дуже
здивувались Друзі там щотижня в кулуарах
змінюється виставки експозиції для кого
вони для оцих самотніх кулуарів де
Бродять депутати раз на місяць друге Я
хочу нагадати що військові працюють
безвихідних Скажіть будь ласка чому
Верховна Рада України в пленарному
режимі працює два дні на тиждень А коли
на місяць два дні на місяць а коли не
дай Бог Там на три години довше
попрацюється то це подвиг нам оголошують
що роксалана Незламна стефанчук
незмінний там і так далі що відбувається
друзі Ми маємо працювати в нормальному
режимі два пленарних тижня як треба той
більше дійсно збиратись на позачергові
засідання якщо треба такі важливі
прийняти рішення як Постанову яку ми
сьогодні говоримо працювати нормально В
комітетах комітети мають бути відкритими
для преси канал Рада має все це
транслювати і ви маєте отримати повний
доступ до тих рішень які приймає
парламент дуже важливо відновити години
запитань до уряду Я наголошую що
протягом двох років повномасштабного
вторгнення Була одна така година в
вересні цього року і крапка на цьому все
завершилося в нас уряду немає у нас
виконуючі обов'язки вже у нас уряд
виконуючих обовяз
і тому дійсно для влади сьогодні кончу
необхідно переформатувати уряд створивши
професійний відповідальний
проєвропейський пронатівський уряд
національної єдності не обслуги банкової
під назвою міністри а професійний уряд
національної єдності Ну і останнє
абсолютно справедливо зазначив Петро
Олексійович що парламент - це незалежна
інституція і статус народного депутата
він визначається відповідним
законодавством очевидно що голова
Верховної Ради не директоркугоспу а
робота депутатів Верховної Ради вона не
оцінюється за критеріями екселівських
табличок І знаєте там як надої молока у
корови Хто скільки там е чого надаїв і
так далі Це абсолютно інші критерії
професійності відповідальності і таке
інше І тому ми би дуже хотіли щоби Ну от
Голова Верховної Ради перестав А
перешкоджати діяльності народних
депутатів і щонайменше 10 представників
нашої фракції будуть звертатися до
судових органів щодо протиправних дій як
керівництва парламенту яке блокує наші
міжнародні відрядження так і постанови
уряду і я хочу зазначити що ми будемо
говорити і про незаконність цієї
постанови в контексті депутаток місцевих
органів влади Я хочу нагадати що Ці
жінки не отримують жодної копійки від
бюджету з як зарплату в той же час ну
катастрофічні випадки коли Мам
заручників військовополонених азовців не
випускають закордонно акції протесту на
підтримку їх синів тільки тому що вони
депутатки місцевих органів влади що таке
відбувається що за сегрегація за
соціальною ознакою і ви знаєте ми
скільки доклали зусиль для того аби
жінок в політиці стало більше в місцевих
владах сьогодні незаконними діями уряду
от Всі ці речі які теж є частиною нашої
євроатлантичної інтеграції вони
перекреслюються тому звичайно цьому
свавілю Ми будемо протистояти і ще раз
Закликаємо колег від всіх фракцій
долучитися до підписання нашої постанови
яка буде спільною сильною позицією і
закликом до країн членів ЄС для того аби
15 грудня на єврораді Ми отримали
позитивний сигнал щодо початку офіційних
перемовин про вступ України до ЄС Дуже
дякуємо Дякую Ірино шановні журналісти
чи є запитання так є можна Петро
Олексійович Я зараз дивлюся Українську
правду і глава МЗС Угорщини підтвердив
що ви збиралися таки зустрічатися з
органом можете розказати що там ви
збиралися робити І що обговорювати
респект Українській правді і ее Я Хочу
наголосити
наступне
дійсно Я і мої служби Звернулися до
лідерів держав які умовно відносять до
скептиків серед них є і Угорщина і
Словаччина і інша держави
де я запропонував
зустрітися обговорити ситуацію для того
щоби
переконати лідерів держав яких я дуже
добре
знаю Я маю дуже великий досвід проводити
позитивні рішення і в частині
ратифікації угоди по асоціації 14 151
роках і ратифікацію угоди по безвізовий
режим і фкацію угоди по поглидну та
всеохоплюючу зону вільної торгівлі і в
тому числі і зараз забезпечення
прийняття рішення єврокомісію про
початок переговорів про
членство декілька керівників держав та
урядів відповіли мені і
запросили ці зустрічі мали
відбутися їх було декілька в
листопаді я звернувся офіційно з
проханням дати в листопаді дозвіл на
виїзд мені було
відмовлено в грудні подібних зустрічей
не планувалося
мені навмисно було виділено е в
розпорядженні з 1 грудня ви можете легко
переконатися що частина керівників е
європейських держав В цей день і весь
початок грудня і по досі знаходяться на
кліматичному саміті в Еміратах
і в даному
випадку ще раз наголошую що з першго по
ме в мене були лише зустрічі в Польщі і
в Сполучених Штатах Америки
але країни де я планував зустрічатися з
керівництвом це є члени Європейського
Союзу це є члени НАТО і сам факт
членства зазначає їх статус як наших
партнерів Вони мають голосувати за
виділення нам 50 мльрдів євро
макрофінансової допомоги Вони мають
голосувати за те щоби запросити нас в
НАТО на вашингтонському саміті і з ними
мають працювати всі хто може всі хто і
знає для того щоби забезпечити
позитивний результат Я працюю над цим
все своє політичне життя а з 14-го року
Це є мій перший пріоритет так само як
членство України в ЄС та нато крім
Перемоги нашої є засадничими позиціями
нашої політичної сили і нормами
Конституції Тому рішення яке було
прийнято воно було прийнято безглузде
безпідставне і таке яке дискредитує не
лише опози
а демократію в Україні
і все ми ще раз наголошую не буде такого
коли голова верховної ради - Це не є
Голова колгоспу А голова Служби Безпеки
України не
є дільничим
НКВС який має щось підписувати або
дозволяти чи не дозволяти це безглуздо
Конституція каже що уряд є
підконтрольний і і підзвітний
парламент а спроба деяких прихильників
авторитарної моделі Кажуть що у нас уряд
тепер буде дозволяти депутатів тримаючи
їх на
гачку виїжджати чи не
виїжджати наша позиція уряд буде
підконтрольний Конституція відновить
свою дію ми будемо демократичною
державою ми я за це бився все своє
політичне життя і я з точки зору
демократії з точки зору перешкоджання
авторитаризму не піду ні на які
компроміси але зараз ми маємо говорити
не про те зараз у нас перший пріоритет
єдність єдність навколо збройних сил
єдність навколо нашого вступу в ЄС та
НАТО і припинити ці дешеві політиканські
трюки
які виходять з бажання тих чи іншихд
ставників влади погратися на рейтингах
не
час прийнято рішення в тому числі в
якому брала участь пані Ірина в діалогах
мене що не проводити вибори я це
підтверджую підпис пані Ірини Там стоїть
і Пані Іванки Мені здається теж але там
була ще одна позиція що всі фракції
парламенту стоять за те щоби приб
рабську систему виїзду депутатів для
здійснення політичної діяльності в тому
числі і за кордон Хочу
наголосити що я не призначений
президентом так само і як наші колеги не
призначений урядом і ми несемо
відповідальність перед своїми виборцями
за реалізацію нашої передвиборчої
програми і подібні
дії некомпетентних людей я не знаю чим
вони керуються Чи це кроти Чи це корисні
ідіоти але це точно не український
інтерес ще раз наголошую відповідаючи на
ваше питання що час зустрічі під час
мого виїзду вже минув мені не дали
дозволу на виїзд зустрічі були зірвані і
я з цього приводу не робив
прес-конференцій не робив заяв
це все
зробили безглузді
безвідповідальні політикани які
намагалися використати і керівництво
Верховної Ради мені соромно за це
парламент втратив суб'єктність і
керівництво СБУ мені теж соромно за це
ви можете саме легко здогадатися хто є
автором цієї провокації ще одне
уточнення Вибачте будь ласка от 90%
відряджень депутатів європейської
содарності За ці два роки і 100%
відряджень Петра Олексійовича коли його
випускали були за власний рахунок або за
рахунок сторони яка запрошувала зараз
верховні від Верховної Ради говорять
Десь три десятки слуг народу знаходяться
на округах в Штатах до речі зараз
парламентські тижні
в Сполучених Штатах і в принципі всі
конгресмени сенатори не в своїх округах
не в Штатах а в Вашингтоні І от ви
знаєте ми неодноразово подавали так само
запит до голови Верховної Ради щодо
підзвітності парламенту щодо того які
кошти витрачаються на телеканал Рада Які
кошти ідуть там на відрядження депутатів
нам відмовляють в цих відповідях чому це
ж кошти платників бюджету і нам здається
тут треба дуже чітко про це сказати тому
що ходять такі чутки що деякі
відрядження з охороною з обслугою з
радниками порадниками е
прессекретарями цими каналом рада
обходяться бюджету там в кілька сотень а
тисяч Гринь
мільмільйони Да і кажуть що навіть на
чартерних літаках хтось там в Америку
летить Тому все це дуже і дуже цікаво і
ми Закликаємо рахункову палату А це її
обов'язок перед Верховною Радою в тому
числі перед українським суспільством
перед журналістами оприлюднити дуже
ретельний звіт як це було в випадку з
роботою Міністерства оборони Коли
проаналізували все і побачили яйця по 17
От такий звіт оприлюднити щодо роботи
Верховної Ради України да Що там за
студії яким здається в оренду каналрада
кінокіт кінособака Хто там ще залишився
да на аутсорсингі от щоби оце все
відповіді суспільство почуло тому що
сьогодні коли кожна копійка має іти на
збройні сили України от вона має йти на
збройні сили України і до речі завтра
Петро Олексійович проанонсуйте да тому
що е Ми би хотіли тоді щоби статистика
була не тільки відряджень верховно до
речі ще одна дуже важлива історія от я є
в офіційному делегації парламенту
з лютого цього року парламентської
асамблеї ОБСЄ дуже пишаюсь цим тому що
знаєте я туди увійшла замість Нестора
Шуфрича і це була дуже велика наша
боротьба Парламентська щоби вигнати всіх
опзжестів з офіційних делегацій і щоби
туди увійшли представники інших
демократичних фракцій парламенту наша
фракція До речі делегувала Петра
Порошенка тоді в парламентську асамблею
Ради Європи але офіс президента
викреслили В нас тепер офіс президента
вирішує кого можна включати в делегацію
кого ні викресли Петра олексівича звідти
бо вирішили що до кавенщиків треба
додати Та адущ весі ну така тепер склад
там є делегації Дякую Ніні з вашого
дозволу Я хотів би ще раз додати дуже
важливу деталь до запитання пані
Оленки перша
позиція всі деталі поїздки в Сполучені
Штати і до Польщі були узгоджені з
українським МЗС
детально і ретельно
проінформованя і друга позиція
поїздки ті що були погоджені і ті що
мали статися були детально погоджені з
партнерами І зараз я отримую численні
дзвінки не лише від десятків іноземних
журналістів з проханням пояснити мені
нема чого
пояснювати Я не знаю як пояснити дії
української влади і пропонує негайно
вжити заходів для того щоб
продемонструвати
єдність але і позиції про те що А можете
пояснити А як Вони збираються проводити
рішення якщо вони не ведуть
діалог Може хтось не знає що Орбана
запросили з візитом до України запросив
особисто
Зеленський і цього візиту не відбулося
Може хтось не знає що було декілька
звернень щодо візитів до Угорщини які не
були підтверджую і замість того щоби
скористатися моїм дипломатичним досвідом
моїми зв'язками моїм авторитетом для
вирішення питань
держави з незрозумілих мені причин було
прийнято абсолютно дріб'язкове абсолютно
некомпетентна позиція внутрішнього
політичної
боротьби на жаль президента Зеленського
саме Так це формурують формулюють наші
партнери з Європейського Союзу Я думаю
що кожен з цього приводу зробить і
висновки і уроки єдність зараз понад усе
е розхитування човна може привести до
Національної катастрофи ми в
європейськії солідарності
твердо виходимо саме з цього дякую
Дякую колеги на завершення А можна ще
уточнення дивіться там в нас коли